Sam Harris I'm from Southern California
and I was raised in a totally secular
home so I'm not I'm not reacting in my
criticism of religion I'm not reacting
against any kind of fundamentalist
upbringing and but nor was I told that
there was no God it was really not a
subject of conversation so my rather
strident criticism of religion is really
a product of very recent events I mean
in my case it's September 11th 2001 so
it's my upbringing isn't so informative
of my views at the moment
well it was two things one just the and
the rather obvious liability of
religious certainty was was made
extraordinarily clear on that day and we
were having people flying planes into
our buildings for explicitly religious
reasons but what was also made clear
that we were going to deny the religious
rationale because of our own attachment
to our own religious myths I mean the
only language we could find as a culture
to comfort ourselves was to endorse our
own God talk so I suddenly saw faith
playing both sides of the board in a in
a very dangerous game where we as a
nation in prosecuting our war on terror
which was obviously a necessary thing to
do though calling it a war on terror I
think it's rather silly but we we were
consoling ourselves with our own
religious certainties you know in very
much in the language of Christian
fundamentalism that the president comes
before Congress and talks about God not
being indifferent to freedom and fear as
an atheist I hear that exactly the way I
would hear someone saying Zeus is not
indifferent to freedom and fear I mean
it is a an uncannily strange and empty
utterance and yet our culture is is is
now programmed not to notice how strange
and empty it is and it does really
significant work and so we see things
like stem cell research and other causes
that upon which the lives and and and
happiness of millions of people really
turn get subverted by religious thinking
and explicitly religious thinking
well I spent a lot of time thinking
about and exploring spiritual experience
and our contemplative traditions mostly
in an Eastern context in Buddhism and
Hinduism but I've also sees you read
much of the contemplatively Tura Chur of
Christianity and Judaism and Islam so
I've been interested in religion for at
least twenty years and interested in
spiritual experience and and have spent
a lot of time practicing meditation and
studying with various meditation masters
in India and Nepal and spending months
and weeks on on retreat just practicing
meditation very much the way up you know
monastic would in in the Buddhist
tradition so I'm the concerns of
religious people the ethical and the and
the spiritual concerns of religious
people are something that I I think I
understand and I take very seriously I
mean I take very seriously the
possibility of experiencing the world
the way Buddha and Jesus and other
famous patriarchs and matriarchs seem to
have experience the world and I I think
we want to actualize that kind of
experience
if it's possible to love your neighbor
as yourself I'm interested in learning
how to do that I just don't think we
have to believe anything on insufficient
evidence in order to
you